[Music]
hallo you took justice in my friends
this is Grinch in here welcome to the
fourth episode of Queen trap sack lines
in this episode I'm going to show you
one of the modern line heart trap which
happens against Philidor defense from
the white perspective where you can
actually trap your opponent Queen the
opening arises after the following water
that is e for ePHI Knight to f3 d6 d4
Knight to d7 and Bishop to c4 now in my
dirty chess tricks fifth episode I have
covered this position in detail where I
have covered all the moves such as
Bishop to e7 Knight to f6 at six and
even c6 with some devastating tricky
lines in this video we are going to
concentrate on the moves c6
as if we check this position in database
you will find out that here the c6 has
been highest Lee played and one of the
most popular choice from black side
after the move c6 lionheart trapline
goes as follows
white continue with the Moon Knight to
g5 attacking on f7 so black responds his
force Black has to play Knight to at six
and after that here the main line
continued with the move castle on the
Kings side but instead of that fight
place this very tricky move a foe and
the trap is set right here black can
avoid this trap by playing he captures
d4 where the middle game will continue
but more often you will find out that
many people continue here with Bishop to
e7 because it's a natural looking move
in this position black not only attacked
the night but he also prepared himself
castle on the Kings side if it's
required
well indeed everything looks so natural
and very good except there is one
problem after this moon by force black
is going to lose his queen ha ha ha well
you don't believe me right
but it's indeed true before I move on I
like you to pause this video and find
out a sequence where you can by force
win black screen
you
okay let's get started
the first obvious movies Bishop captures
app seven BAM
so it's a check and kindly note King
cannot go to their fate because after 96
black is going to lose the Queen so this
piece signifies has to be accepted so
the force reply is Knight captures
epsilon where after that white will
continue with his merry night journey 96
attacking the Queen and this wrap around
Queen has to square where she can go the
first more I want to consider it is
Queen to if I check which looks very
natural attacking the White King and
getting out of the attack but here comes
Bishop to D to counter attacking the
Queen and I think you can already see
here that Queen can never goes on this
two squares because night c7 will NAB
the Queen
so that means black response is force
here black has the only square left that
is Queen to b6 but after that white
reveal the whole point to play the moon
a for instead of Castle e 5 so now the
Queen has the only square that is Queen
captures b2 and after that did you see
it yep it's very easy
Bishop to c3 and bye-bye miss Queen
you
the second move left for the black bean
is to play Queen to b6 and I think this
line is more trickier because after the
obvious move if I black queen has a nice
escaping rule Queen check c3 and now
Queen to c4 so not only safeguarding the
Queen but attacking the knight and maybe
black thinks that okay I can give up my
rook and later on trap that night and I
get at least a playable position so the
biggest question arise how you going to
trap black win from this position kindly
pause the video and find out a way to
again trap the black baby
well to my surprise all the games in
database continue from here might to c7
check and then having the rook in the
corner but instead of that White has a
better continuation which trap the black
queen and that start with Knight
captures g7 check now it doesn't matter
whether King goes on f8 or d8 let's say
King to f8 looks more natural
well after that White has this sneaky
move in the picture that is b3 and if
you carefully look at this position now
Queen has the only two squares left
either Queen to be Phi or Queen twin six
and it doesn't matter whether the Queen
goes to any squares let's say Queen to
e6 and after that our amazing night
perform his very important duty Knight
to e6 King to G and now Knight to c7
grabbing the sweetie and in fact killing
the black on the spot
so this is a very wonderful line Hart
trap exist in the Philadelphia's which
can by force NAB the black Queen and
gives you a very fast victory thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment on my video
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care
you